l'avion le plus mystérieux du monde est
sorti de l'ombre c'est un bombardier
nucléaire le blackjack les soviétiques
l'ont montré au secrétaire américain à
la défense au nom de la glace note
écologie la querelle des voitures
propres rebondissent l'autriche menace
de boycotter les voitures françaises si
elles ne s'équipent pas de pot
d'échappement
lompo loin des femmes traite et bientôt
effet cela se passe dans l'église
anglicane qui a dit oui
les autres églises ne sont pas prêtes à
suivre ce mouvement
bonsoir et tout d'abord cette histoire
c'est celle d'un miracle il a eu lieu à
lourdes bien sûr la semaine dernière un
homme paralysé depuis 19 ans est remis à
marcher dix minutes après une onction au
malade
l'émirat qui lie à ceux qui croient et
ceux qui n'y croient pas l'église elle
même reste très discrète sur ces
phénomènes
on peut en tout cas écoutez le
témoignage de cet homme miraculé
recueillis par rémy roche dans les
vosges auparavant j'ajoute juste deux
précisions
la profession de cet homme il est
charpentier et puis son prénom
il s'appelle joseph la démarche n'est
pas même hésitante l'alluré décider
pourtant il n'ya pas huit jours joseph
charpentier ne se déplacer qu'en
fauteuil roulant
paraplégique depuis 1969 à la suite
d'une intervention chirurgicale sur la
colonne vertébrale est toujours là
dedans d'hôpitaux au centre de
rééducation 19 ans de souffrances et de
sacrifices pour cet ancien électricien
des houillères de lorraine les médecins
ne lui ont guère laissé d'espoir de
retrouver l'usagé de ses jambes
mais l'épreuve confort et développe la
foi catholique de joseph il prit matin
et soir et chaque année parfois même
deux fois par an il se rend à lourdes
comme la semaine dernière au milieu de
la communauté des lion de juda j'ai reçu
une forte chaleur qui m'est montée par
les cas qui a commencé par les pieds qui
monte jusqu'au de mon coeur et c'est là
que j'ai vu que je vais seniors en moi
et que je ne suis que je disais que je
vais me lever et que j'ai vu un lion de
juda et cet homme m'a pris par les mains
après j'ai dit tirer un petit peu je me
suis levé et je me suis mis en marché
pour l'heure cette soudaine guérison
ciel bouleversé proche de joseph
charpentier ne suscite que des
commentaires prudents de la part du
médecin qui n'a pas encore constaté les
progrès étonnants de son malade et se
refuse à toute déclaration officielle
il nous a pourtant confié qu'il avait
bien eu à faire un cas de paraplégie qui
n'était pas médicalement traité en vue
d'une guérison circonspection également
à l'évêché de metz où l'on remarque que
l'intéressé ne s'est pas présentée au
euros des constatations à lourdes où
dansent enfin de l'ancien curé de joseph
qui parlent toutefois de prodigieux
événements je ne pensais pas que un jour
je connaîtrais quelqu'un qui se serait
ainsi guéri un autre jury par miracle
puis un miracle c'est un grand mot nous
laissons l'appréciation du mot miracle
aussi bien à la médecine qu'à l'autorité
de l'église en décider ce miracle entre
guillemets puisqu'il n'a été confirmée
ni par l'église ni par les médecins a
donc eu lieu à lourdes la semaine
dernière au cours d'un pèlerinage de la
communauté du lion de juda c'est l'une
des communautés de ce que l'on appelle
les charismatiques des chrétiens qui
veulent rester au sein de l'église mais
qui vivent leur foi d'une manière
différente une communauté très axé sur
l'inspiration du saint-esprit est
justement sur la guérison
pascal deschamps philippe etcheverry
outre joseph charpentier une dizaine de
membres de cette communauté aurait été
guérie
ici à lourdes lors de cette cérémonie
jeudi dernier paralysé qui ont retrouvé
l'usagé de leurs jambes ou muet qui ont
retrouvé celle de la parole
pas de doute pour les responsables de la
communauté ils ont été touchés par la
grâce de prière d'invocation de du
christ et de son amour et de sa
puissance de résurrection c'était dans
une liturgie sacramentelle il y avait le
sacrement des malades et au cours duquel
plusieurs personnes qui sont ensuite
venus nous trouver pour être un peu
médicalement confirmées
venez donc trouver les médecins de notre
organisation eh bien on a testé
qu'il y avait eu des nets soulagement
par exemple cet homme dont le prénom est
joseph les avant de crier au miracle
l'église demande à voir car pour le
moment aucun de ces malades ne s'est
soumis à la procédure classique une
visite au bureau des constatations
médicales ou des médecins vérifie le
caractère soudain et inexpliquée de
toute guérison l'église depuis toujours
le magistère de l'église n'a avoué
éviter l'ambiguïté d'une guérison qui
puisse être subjectivement eaux
considérées comme justes mais qui ne
puisse pas avoir une base objective et
depuis des siècles ils ont l'église
sastre à un processus de reconnaissance
médical des guérisons et à lourdes
nous avons pris les critères de l'église
qui date de mulhouse 8e 7e 10 ans comme
base ainsi depuis 1858 5000 cas de
guérisons ont été présentés à l'église
soixante quatre seulement ont eu droit
au label miracle après l'histoire du
jour l'image du jour cfl d'un bombardier
beaucoup moins pacifiques et pourtant il
s'agit bien de détente internationale
les soviétiques ont montré aujourd'hui
aux américains et au monde entier
puisqu'il y avait des journalistes
l'avion le plus secret du monde un
bombardier nucléaire dont aucune photo
n'avait circulé jusqu'à présent en
occident les soviétiques joue la glace
nost c'est à dire la transparence dans
les relations internationales
ils ont montré l'avion à frank carlucci
le secrétaire américain à la défense
gilles rabin l'avion le plus secret du
monde ressemble bien à cette
extrapolation dessinée à partir des trop
rares renseignements obtenus jusqu'ici
un des services secrets occidentaux
frank carlucci le secrétaire d'état
américain à la défense a donc pu
constater aujourd'hui que ces espions
travail et bien non seulement il a pu
voir ce super bombardiers stratégiques
nucléaires 40 mètres de long sept mille
deux cents kilomètres de rayon d'action
capable aussi bien de voler à deux fois
la vitesse du son en haute altitude
qu'au ras du sol pour déjouer les
surveillances radars mais il a pu aussi
installé dans le cockpit
aux commandes de l'appareil
je ne suis pas un officier de
renseignement je ne sais pas distinguer
un instrument d'un autre a déclaré à sa
descente de secrétaires d'état américain
qui a pourtant été dans le passé le
directeur adjoint de la cia
frank carlucci pour qui ces pilotes 2029
le chasseur le plus performant de
l'armée rouge sont allés jusqu'à
effectuer des figures d'acrobatie les
plus difficiles ici un tonneau à 8 face
est jamais la glace note la transparence
n'a été aussi concrète qu'aujourd'hui
entre soviétiques et américains et pour
nous européens c'est l'occasion de
découvrir un homme nouveau de la
politique américaine fait le secrétaire
à la défense jacques carles uci alors
jacques à bouchehr d'habitude vous êtes
à washington frank carlucci c'est
maintenant un homme clé de la politique
américaine
oui et c'est un homme qui incarne
parfaitement la nouvelle politique
détendue les nouveaux rapports détendu
et décrispé entre moscou et washington
il a occupé effectivement un certain
nombre de postes importants au pentagone
à la cia
bien qu'ils soient pas très connu du
grand public et le contraste est
saisissant entre carlucci et son
prédécesseur monsieur caspar weinberger
wennberg r&s qu'on appelait un faucon un
dur
quelqu'un qui disait avec les russes il
n'y a qu'un langage employé c'est le
langage de la fermeté et monsieur
wennberg et réclamer toujours davantage
de crédits pour acheter davantage de
chars d'avions et de sous marins
nucléaires
mais voyez vous ce qu'il ya de plus
remarquable trouve dans cette évolution
de l'administration reagan depuis huit
ans et que ronald reagan qui a été élu
en 1981 réélu confirmé en 84 sur des
thèmes quasiment de guerre froide
en tout cas violemment anti soviétique
ce mandat présidentiel de reggane
s'achève sur une politique je dirais du
sourire avec les russes
alors comment on peut expliquer une
telle évolution un tel revirement on
peut le dire oui il y à il ya une
évolution presque un revirement et il ya
surtout quatre semaines depuis depuis
c'est au cours de ces dernières années
geneve 1985 à reykjavik en islande en
1986 à washington en décembre dernier et
récemment donc fin mai à moscou avec un
décembre à washington la signature du
traité éliminant toutes les fusées de
portée intermédiaire et avec aussi ne
l'oublions pas
certains déjà l'intérieur en urss et
avec l'ambitieux programme de réforme de
monsieur gorbatchev
merci jacques le proche-orient
maintenant toujours pas de réaction des
palestiniens l'ol paie ils sont toujours
réunis pour examiner les conséquences de
la décision du roi hussein décision de
rompre les liens entre cisjordanie et
jordanie une décision qui met les
palestiniens au pied du mur et qui a
provoqué en tout cas une nouvelle
tension en cisjordanie occupée par
israël
jacques merlino huit palestiniens ont
été expulsés par les israéliens le jour
même eu précisément une grève générale
était a pris dans les territoires
occupés en signe de protestation contre
ces expulsions
une nouvelle épreuve de force ou une
volonté de provocation qui s'est
traduite par une série de manifestations
violentes
deux palestiniens ont été blessés par
balles près de hébron est un jeune
palestinien de 18 ans était tué à
naplouse
cela porte 236 le nombre de morts en
huit mois dinky fada la révolution des
pierres mais derrière ces images
devenues d'une terrible banalité
apparaissent plus profonde inquiétude et
un grand désarroi après la décision du
roi hussein de couper tout lien
administratif entre la jordanie et la
cisjordanie
les huit cent mille habitants de cette
terre se retrouvent aujourd'hui dans un
vide juridique ayant eu d'équivalent
dans le monde
c'est un territoire sans état qui va
payer les salaires des enseignants qui
délivrera les certificats de naissance
ou de décès qui tiendra à l'état civil
qui va gérer les lieux saints qui
délivrera les passeports
autant de question actuellement sans
réponse autant d'incertitudes qui
pourrait encore accroître la violence
que venu ici quotidienne le
cessez-le-feu entre l'iran et l'irak ce
n'est pas pour tout de suite il ya
quelques jours le secrétaire général de
l'onu monsieur perez de cuellar se
montrait relativement optimiste il
pensait pouvoir fixer très vite une date
pour ce cessez le feu
en fait les conditions préalables
exigées par les deux belligérants sont
telles que la perspective de paix recul
par exemple à l'instant même je viens
d'apprendre que le porte parole de la
délégation irakienne à l'onu vient de
dire que l'irak n'accepterait pas le
fait accompli d'un cessez le feu décrété
sans son accord par le secrétaire
général des nations-unies
tout de suite nous retrouverons paul
nahon à l'onu à new york
monsieur perez de cuellar a décidément
bien du mal à imposer un cessez le feu
aux belligérants
sur le terrain d'abord le secrétaire
général des nations unies attend le
rapport des experts qui l'a envoyé sur
place un rapport qui confirmera l'emploi
massif d'armes chimiques par l'irak
ces derniers jours à new york la
délégation irakienne veut entamer des
négociations directes avec l'iran qui
elle ne veut pas entendre parler pour le
moment deux face à face avec son ennemi
l'iran réclame d'abord l'entrée en
vigueur d'un cessez-le-feu le retrait
des troupes sur les frontières
internationales et les échanges de
prisonniers de guerre le conseil de
sécurité lui attend et laisse toujours
carte blanche au secrétaire général des
nations unies qui nous avait déclaré la
semaine dernière
c'est une affaire je dirais tout d'abord
de sérénité et de patience de
persévérance et c'est une grande volonté
de réussir monsieur perez de cuellar
peut s'il le veut décréter immédiatement
un cessez-le-feu sur le terrain mais le
secrétaire général des nations unies
préfère attendre que la position des
belligérants se rapproche un peu plus
c'est vrai on n'arrête pas une guerre de
huit ans en une semaine ce matin un
diplomate des nations unies mme affirmé
que la négociation entre l'irak et
l'iran durer au moins jusqu'à la fin du
mois d'août les femmes et l'église leurs
conditions très défavorables au sein de
l'église est peut-être le plus grand
anachronisme du monde moderne
mais ce qui s'est passé hier soir à
canterbury en angleterre pendant le
congrès de l'église anglicane est sans
doute un tournant dans le monde chrétien
des femmes anglicane vont pouvoir
devenir évêque sous certaines conditions
c'est une première brèche pour l'instant
l'église catholique ne semble pas prête
du tout à suivre le mouvement
de ce côté là il n'y a pas de miracle
michel mompontet
one 423 voix pour 28 contre les évêques
anglicans du monde entier ont tranché
ils auront désormais des consoeurs
les femmes pourront accéder en effet au
sein de cette église à la fonction
épiscopale réservé jusque là aux seuls
or les traditionalistes qui jusqu'àlors
s'y opposent et ont perdu ils ne peuvent
désormais plus tourner le dos à l'avenir
de l'église qui serait justement ces
femmes
mais cette victoire doit être tempérée
déjà au sein de cette église anglicane
plus souple et si différente de l'église
catholique romaine
les femmes avaient accès à la prêtrise
mariage baptême mais pas l'eucharistie
réservé aux hommes il faudra maintenant
attendre au moins dix ans avant de voir
une femme évêque en angleterre mais aux
états unis
déjà la première ordination et prévenant
heures mois l'église anglicane a donc
franchi le pas un pas que l'on est
absolument pas prêt de faire dans
l'église romaine souvenez-vous 1979
washington lors d'une visite papale
c'est l'événement la mère elisabeth
mccain tente le tout pour le tout elle
demande au pape le droit à devenir
évêques pour les femmes la réponse de
jean paul ii est alors sans appel la
prêtrise est exclusivement réservé aux
hommes
jésus-christ a montré le premier exemple
il n'y avait pas parmi les apôtres de
femmes
dieu s'est fait homme
un chai j'écris il aurait pu se faire
femmes c'est vrai et il empêche que un
vrai problème existe celui de la place
de la fonction du rôle des femmes dans
l'église mais les femmes catholiques ne
doivent pas ce soir désespéré et se
souvenir qu'il ya quelques siècles
encore elle n'avait pas d'âme
aujourd'hui elles ont presque une mitre
chez les anglicans tout du moins le
reste de l'actualité maintenant rang
bref en images en couleur avec alain
labouze à commencer par l'irlande du
nord où les terroristes redouble de
violence depuis quelques jours
nouvel attentat en irlande du nord une
mine a explosé ce matin dans le village
de carlan de faisant six blessés légers
parmi une patrouille auxiliaires de
l'armée britannique l'ira a revendiqué
cet attentat qui survient au lendemain
de l'attaqué contre la caserne
londonienne une nouvelle vague de
violence contre des cibles militaires
britanniques est à craindre dans les
prochaines semaines
nouvelle défection à palerme le chef de
la brigade mobile
anthony nonne ichi a présenté sa
démission deux jours après celle du juge
giovanni falcone
les raisons invoquées sont les mêmes
laquelle il ya possibilité de lutter
contre la mafia dans cette ville le
prédécesseur d'anthony laup nichi lenica
sarah avait été assassiné en 1985 par la
mafia
situation bloquée pour le ms petersburgh
ce caboteur chargé de déchets
radioactifs autrichien est toujours à la
recherche d'un port d'accueil en mer
noire
depuis un mois la turquie refuse en
effet de recevoir le caboteur ouest
allemand la roumanie se dit prête à
donner son feu vert pour que le bateau
remonte le danube jusqu'à son port
d'origine
mais cette éventualité est techniquement
irréalisable en raison du bas niveau
d'eau du danube en cette saison
la fin du cauchemar pour cet enfant de 8
ans marco fiora vient d'être libéré
après 17 mois de captivité enlevé le 2
mars 1987 à turin ils étaient détenus
dans les montagnes du sud de l'italie
les ravisseurs auraient décidé de
libérer marco en raison des vastes
opérations de ratissage de la police
dans la région
le petit garçon est très affaibli et
semble avoir été maltraité au cours de
sa détention
un nouveau succès de la chirurgie la
réimplantation d'un pied un jeune homme
dont le pied justement avait été
sectionné dans un accident de moto cela
fait passer cette fois saint germain en
laye à bordeaux il y a quelques jours
seulement d'autres chirurgiens avaient
réimplanter les deux jambes un ouvrier
agricole dans ce genre d'opération les
succès sont maintenant de plus en plus
nombreux mais ces opérations restent
rares la plupart du temps la solution de
la médecine pour un membre coupé c'est
l'appareillage la prothèse là aussi il y
à de gros progrès reportage à valenton
jean daniel flaysakier pascal golomer un
accident de moto il y a deux ans une
jambe droite fracturée en trente deux
morceaux et qu'il faudra amputer pour
michel débâtisse il n'était plus
question de reprendre son métier de
routier
pour lui la solution ça a été la pose
d'une prothèse une pause suivi d'une
réadaptation à valenton valenton c'est
un centre où 2000 personnes viennent
chaque année réapprendre à vivre avec un
ou deux membres en moins et un matériel
étranger en plus l'impression d'être
quelqu'un à des handicapés cette
prothèse vous la vivez comme quelque
chose qu'on vous a rajouté ou est ce que
vous l'avez complètement assimilé au
reste de votre corps comment ça se passe
parce que j'ai bien assimilé parce que
mon âge et exane marché puis surtout
pour se retrouver un boulot après
quelques échecs et chaussons marché
quand même les progrès scientifiques
conduisent parfois de drôles de dilemme
d'un côté il ya des techniques
chirurgicales qui s'affine de jour en
jour et qui permettent de tenter de
réimplanter des membres sectionnés sans
garantie de résultat de l'autre des
prothèses qui bénéficie des avancées de
l'électronique de recherche bio
mécanique ou encore des progrès de la
conception assistée par ordinateur
et au bout un choix pas toujours simple
à faire je crois qu'il faut tout faire
pour conserver un membre mais pas aller
au delà du raisonnable et savoir devant
des blessures aussi dit ventes ou des
douleurs intolérables proposé
l'amputation qui permet avec une
prothèse bien adapté de retrouver un
niveau de vie enfin des possibilités
fonctionnelles en tout cas tout à fait
valable quand on voit aujourd'hui des
sportifs handicapés courir le 100 m en
un tout petit peu plus de 11 secondes
les sportifs capables de sauter plus de
deux mètres en hauteur ou bien de
parcourir un kilomètre lancé à skis
après 290 km heure on se dit que le
terme d'un firme n'a plus beaucoup de
signification la lutte contre la
pollution la france montrée du doigt à
l'autriche menace de boycotter les
voitures françaises si elles ne
s'équipent pas de pot d'échappement non
polluants les européens font des efforts
dans ce sens les constructeurs français
traînent les pieds
et pourtant chaque jour la pollution
gagne du terrain dans notre monde
industrialisé à l'un de mes skis dans ce
coffre le pot catalytique considéré
comme une arme un contre la pollution
bien sûr 2 contre les concurrences et ce
deuxième aspect qui est mais aujourd'hui
les constructeurs français d'automobiles
si les autrichiens refusent d'acheter
nos voitures alors qu'elle réponde à
leurs législations
c'est qu'ils sont complices des
allemands disent les fabricants français
leur raisonnement est le suivant d'abord
les allemands grâce à des avantages
fiscaux encourage l'achat par leur
conducteur de pots catalytiques sur leur
territoire ensuite ils brouillent les
accords européens
ils obtiennent que les petites voitures
en soit équipé avant l'échéance prévue
c'est leur intérêt disent les français
en effet pour un pot catalytique de 3000
francs par exemple le surcoût est
d'environ 5% pour un petit modèle 2 me
pour cent pour une voiture moyenne
supérieure il n'est plus que de 1 an et
demi pour cent pour les hauts de gamme
souvent allemande
cette augmentation relative plus
importantes sur les petites voitures
pourraient donc décourager les acheteurs
les constructeurs français traînent les
pieds face à ce problème de plus ils le
font en ordre dispersé peugeot citroën
refuse les pots catalytiques pour les
petites voitures
désuet inefficace distillent leurs
solutions des moteurs plus propres
par contre renault de voix les adoptés à
partir de 1992 en proposant un modèle
économique pour les petites voitures
un danger aujourd'hui c'est que la
législation européenne à ce sujet
partent dans tous les sens en politique
c'est le calme absolu le monde politique
est en vacances et personne pour
l'instant ne déroge à la règle
l'actualité sociale en revanche n'est
qu'en 2000 au mail la rentrée promet
d'être chaude et en ce moment quelques
conflits n'arrivent pas à trouver de
solutions exemple les mine de gardanne
le désaccord entre la cfdt et la cgt
dans ce conflit très longs pourrait même
aboutir à des affrontements
emmanuel vanier l'unité cfdt cgt dans
les manifestations c'était en mai
dernier
depuis entre les deux syndicats la
fracture après des heurts violents avec
la cgt la semaine dernière la cfdt
certes très minoritaire à gardanne a
appelé à la reprise du travail
150 mineurs auraient donné leur accord
mais leur rassemblement prévu demain
matin a été annulé on a eu des menaces
de mort constamment par des hauts
responsables de la cgt on a maintenu
notre appel à une assemblée générale le
mercredi et mardi soir à la sortie des
négociations où il se trouve qu'on a été
tabassé qu'on a trois camarades qui sont
retrouvés aux urgences à l'hôpital
il est évident que dans ces conditions
là nous n'est sortie du conflit
ces menaces sont pures inventions dit la
cgt qui aujourd'hui mène seule une grève
commencée il ya plus de trois mois
plusieurs centaines de grévistes
occupent toujours le carreau de la mine
et le font depuis toujours les mêmes
revendications reprise des négociations
mais pas de reprise du travail sans une
augmentation de 400 francs des salaires
à la cgt on se prépare à un conflit de
longue durée
la cgt est une organisation syndicale
qui a toujours dit la vérité qui a
toujours appuyé les travailleurs et nous
serons toujours à côté des travailleurs
ce n'est pas la cgt qui décidera c'est
les travailleurs qui décideront plus
d'unité syndicale à gardanne un virage
fondamental selon la direction des
houillères qui estime que les non
grévistes sont aujourd'hui majoritaires
prochaines dates clés le saison avec le
retour des vacances des non grévistes
ce jour là seulement on pourra compter
avec précision les forces en présence
mais des deux côtés on craint des
affrontements violents justice avec un
non-lieu pour pascal valérie radeau il
s'agit de ceux chargés de mission la
cncl qui avait été inculpé pour trafic
d'influencé ont accusé d'avoir favorisé
une radio privée
en échange d'un voyage non lieu donc
meeting d'athlétisme à monaco ce soir
avec un très beau 200 m qui sera en fait
la revanche des championnats du monde de
rome l'année dernière calvin smith
l'américain face à gilles quénéhervé
le français dans ce meeting d'autres
épreuves de haut niveau comme le 100 m
qui vient de se courir à l'instant
patrick naf tout de suite d'état de
louis ii à monaco départ du 100 m 1 100
m de très haut niveau malgré l'absence
de lewis et celles de smith qui
participent au 200 m bruno marie rose
est au couloir 2 max morinière couloir 8
entre les deux français le gratin du
sprint avec robinson mitchell stewart
immolance le plus rapide entrée en
action le nigérian immo à sa gauche le
jamaïcain stewart ligne 4 mitchell
d'américains
la victoire n'échappe pas immo en 10
secondes 17 centièmes un excellent
chrono
côté français déception max morinière a
été distancé dès le départ quant à bruno
marie rose
il est nettement dominée par ses
adversaires visiblement beaucoup plus
affûté il est vrai que les américains
sortent des épreuves de qualification
pour séoul confirmation de leur
domination peut être contesté tout à
l'heure sur le 200 m avec la revanche du
championnat du monde entre gilles
quénéhervé et calvin smith ses résultats
du 200 m en tout cas dans la dernière
édition vers 23h la mort d'andré navarra
il s'était ainsi n en italie c'était
l'un des grands virtuoses du violon
c'est l'un des meilleurs représentants
de l'école française il avait 77 ans la
mort aussi de la comédienne hélène
vallier à la suite d'une hémorragie
cérébrale
hélène valley était l'une des quatre
soeurs polyakov aux côtés de marina
vlady d'olga poliakoff et d'odile
versoix elle même décédée en 1981 nous
les voyons ici en 79 toutes les quatre
c'était dans antenne 2006 avant de
terminer ces images de chine des
inondations terribles dans le zhejiang
c'est dans l'est de la chine les pluies
diluviennes un bilan très lourd plus de
700 morts claude crespo
c'est l'armée qui a organisé les
premiers secours assistés par de
nombreuses équipes médicales pour
notamment déplacés vers des zones plus
sûres
les populations en danger cette
catastrophe une des plus graves depuis
cinq siècles touche l'est de la chine
par endroit en une demi journée il est
tombé un demi mètre d'eau au mètre carré
conséquence dix sept mille maisons
effondrées sans réservoir ici
305 qu'on emportées par les pluies
torrentielles première estimation des
dégâts 1 milliard de francs et au même
moment la sécheresse règne dans le sud
est et des chutes de grêle ont endommagé
les terres cultivées du nord-est du pays
en france heureusement les pluies ont
été moins forte mais hier et aujourd'hui
la france a subi bien sûr toute une
série d'orages vous le savez puisque
vous les avez vécu le plus violent a eu
lieu à belfort qui a connu une véritable
mini tornade avec des arbres abattus des
toitures détérioré des voitures
endommagé des lignes électriques et
téléphoniques coupées
la moitié nord de la ville de belfort et
les communes avoisinantes ont subi la
nuit dernière
le bref mais spectaculaire passage d'une
mini-tornade elle a fait même quelques
blessés heureusement légèrement atteints
dans un instant sophie davant dans sa
météo va nous confirmer que demain les
orages seront moins nombreux le temps
devrait s'améliorer en tout cas dans le
nord-ouest le dernier journal ce sera un
peu après 23 heures avec aubry et de
l'air excellente soirée sur antenne 2 à
demain